Follow me back. All right. All right.
All right. Come here, darling. Come
here. Come here. Listen. Listen. If you
follow her, you have to follow me. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Come here. That's my goal.
That's my goal. All right. Not for long.
Not for long. What's your name? Give me
a kiss.
>> I'm secondhand angry for him.
Alhamdulillah. For Islam, guys.
Alhamdulillah. The Muslim community
hasn't dropped this low. Wow.
Islam
is raising funds to establish a masjid
and community center in Norway and they
urgently need your support. This
donation will be a for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation, you will in be
reaping the reward. Click the link and
donate what you can. Asalama
brothers and sisters and dear friends, I
sat at this table wanted to do a
reaction video about message to Conor
McGregor. While I was looking at that, I
came across this Instagram video where I
wanted to bang my head uh against the
fireplace. Actually, um you know, I
thought maybe I'll come back to my
senses of what I saw. So many men are
going to be biting their fingers out of
rage and anger. And it just shows you
how feminized and how much of cowards
men have become. This video you're about
to watch is of some influencer who is
chatting up two girls and one of the
girls is chatting up. You watch it for
yourself. That's what I'm going to say.
You are going to lose it. Inshallah.
>> You on my Instagram, too.
>> Only if I can have you both at the same
time.
[Music]
>> Follow me back.
>> All right. All right. All right. Come
here, darling. Come here. Come here.
>> Listen, listen. If you follow her, you
have to follow me.
>> Wait, wait, wait. That's my goal. That's
my goal.
>> Yo, one second, bro. But can you just
Can you just imagine this, bro? I really
want like alhamdulillah for Islam. what
the non-Muslim men and women are going
through. I just say alhamdulillah for
Islam. I know I came from not this kind
of disgusting.
Alhamdulillah for Islam. Can you
imagine? You're saying there's next man
moving to your girl or your wife
and she's about to give her Instagram.
You're like a waste piece of crap. You
piece your piece of crap in front of her
eyes. And you go, "Hey, hey, you need to
if you add her, you need to add me. I'm
her man.
Brother, I don't know if I should slap
your face or intellectually or I don't
know. Let's carry on. I'm I'm busy, bro.
>> All right. Not for long.
>> Not for long.
>> You're going to message You're going to
message me, though?
>> Yeah. You going to come back to the
villa tonight?
>> Drop me a message, sweetheart. What's
your name?
>> Give me a kiss on Jake.
>> What a violation. She kisses another man
in front of her boyfriend.
Sorry guys, I haven't posted. The screen
hasn't posted. I'm just um just in
shock. My sister's in shock. And and and
watch what happens next. Watch what this
guy who's moving to his girl. This cuck.
Yeah. Let's see what what he adviser
going to give him.
>> Sorry, brother. Game's the game, mate.
You got L off, bro. You You look like a
cuck on live right now.
>> Yeah, it's alive as well.
>> Yeah,
>> mate. You can't you can't have that,
bro. You are. I know,
>> bro. That guy who's just violated your
whole honor dignity, your manhood.
He's telling you, bro, you're looking
like a Can you do something and
dump her now? The guy is telling you,
listen, it's painful for him to see the
guy's moving to your girl. What did he
do? Check this out,
>> mate. Tell her, bro. Tell her you're
done right now.
>> Not right now. Not right now.
>> All right. I don't know.
>> You're finished, bro. You're finished.
know what the going on. I just went if
there is there a chance you you go on
with Matty tonight even though your
boyfriend's behind you. She went
>> and her boyfriend I can't
>> I'm secondhand angry for him.
Alhamdulillah for Islam guys.
Alhamdulillah the Muslim community
hasn't dropped this low. Alhamdulillah
the Muslim women have honor and dignity
still.
Wow. Wow. Can you imagine living as a
man? And that's why Allah says in the
Quran, only in the remembrance of Allah
do hearts find peace. And if you forget
his remembrance, you will have a
depressed life. No honor, no dignity, no
shame, nothing. Look at this. You know,
an average man who's getting married,
his wife has been with 8 to 15 men. Back
in the days, this would be classed as
prostitution.
Can you imagine
the lifestyle they living? You know how
depressing is and some of you guys might
look at the other guy who's like the you
know the guy who's getting all the girls
he's also depressed because let me tell
you something I come from a jah men like
that who operated like that deep down
they trusted no woman and they used to
beat women and hate women you know why
cuz they would be like wow I know how
evil you woman can get. I know how
manipul I know how what kind of plots
you can do behind your husbands and
boyfriend's back and they would live
depressed life. You know why? because
they would never trust their own
girlfriend or their wife and it is a
loss loss situation for that for
that guy there who's ching his girl and
for that girl they are so lost look at
that subhan allah say alhamdulillah for
Islam wall when I look at this I say
alhamdulillah of Islam I will not give a
sand particle of Islam if they gave me
the entire globe because I know what it
means to have Islam to dignity dignity,
honor in all aspects of life, Islam
caters for you. Subhan Allah. That's
what I'm going to say, guys. Wallah, I
was not even intending of doing this
video. Another video when I saw this, I
was so enraged. And alhamdulillah, the
Muslims, this is why people are flocking
to Islam because it gives you a way of
life, a dignified, honorable way to
live. Not like this. That's why I say
the western values and Islamic values,
they're not align. Alhamdulillah, they
not align. Subhan Allah. That's all I
have to say. In brothers and sisters,
don't forget to download the Salah Pro
app. It's absolutely for free.
Inshallah, connect yourself back to
Allah through Salah.
Fly overhead.